people think that emotional infatuation
that they feel for someone that they
first met is love yeah that's what they
think they might even describe this as
falling in love or love at first sight
but infatuation is not love infatuation
actually has almost nothing to do with
love you can be infatuated with somebody
and not love them a stalker can be
infatuated with somebody and then kill
them I'm not saying that the infatuation
phase is bad I'm simply saying that it's
a phase it happens at the very beginning
it's the fuel that's supposed there's a
there's a reason for it it has a it has
a function and the infatuation phase
it's supposed to help launch the rocket
and get it off the ground but it's not
going to sustain you for the whole
journey or even for any significant part
of it because infatuation has to give
way to love which isn't to say that love
is less exciting or less intense or less
thrilling quite the opposite in fact
infatuation is fleeting it's thin it's
hormonal love is much realer it's much
deeper it's much more meaningful